the most African American of all the
theaters that were it was in Harlem was
the Lafayette theater by 1912 and after
it was a predominant producer of Black
shows and one of the biggest shows they
did was in 1913 colors show called dark
town of follies it was authored by Lori
hill we went on to do some partnerships
with Romberg actually wrong did the
ragtime pipes of pan so when I wanted to
try to incorporate two other shows this
ragtime idian they would turn to the
black composers were part and partial
putting on the shows even downtown and
what's really interesting about this
show is this show Darktown follies is so
popular that the Ziegfeld comes to see
the show he takes components of the show
downtown for the ziegfeld follies of
1914 but then just recently all right
was engaged by the Museum of Modern Art
who came across some film footage of a
film that was never released with Bert
Williams and when I went to see it I was
just like shocked at how many the
players that I had been researching
we're part of the listing of who was in
the chaos and for my sheet music I was
actually able to help them identify who
was in the movie and then they had some
information about one of the players and
the list thing they found is that he had
his funeral at st. Philip's church in
the 1980s and they wonder if we could
find there any family so I contacted
somebody at st. Philip's is where the
neighborhood's stuff helps and she found
the obituary from the thing and we found
the family was in queens and they came
to see this film and the grandchildren
and great first of all the
great-grandson looked just like his
great-grandfather's in the movie but can
you imagine hearing about your
grandparents and having never seen them
you're great parent and coming they
cried they came to the film to see their
grand great grandfather great
grandfather and three in that lot three
dimensions but see move around and
negotiate the world and other players is
pretty amazing but by then Bert Williams
now was a marquee talent from 1910 till
he died he was a lead performer for
Ziegfeld
and so he's a marquee name and they see
this play Darktown follies they said
well let's make a movie and it was a
mainstream movie it wasn't it i'ma show
black producers during a movie for black
away and say so this could be this is
burnt we entered hugely popular we can
make this great film and put it out
there and the back support him they
brought in these players that were from
the Darktown follies so it was like a
reunion and when you see the film you
ever get a chance to watch it the
interactions everything realize they're
doing dance numbers take back then the
cameraman could just say don't go piss
hair and don't go past here and do it
you know it's no it's no filming it's
they're gonna do a little this little
duel actually realize are doing dances
they really wanted to do Abby Mitchell
cook who sang and performed in two
homemade was will marry cooks wife she's
in the film la brie Hill is a tall
gentleman in the middle of the bullet so
even use their friends as act as extras
and stuff don't even have major parts
but they're showing up in there so he
realize they're all growing out it was
shot in the New Jersey and you realize
they're all going out and the
camaraderie and the sense of what was
going on with that and then it never
gets edited because birth of a nation
comes out and birth of a nation so
poisons the book general market of
thinking this this film would ever fly
that it never gets you know edited and
released so you saw you see talent like
this is this one things like as an
african-american we kind of step back
you see how much into the American
culture this is contribution and you
only like the hallmark names that
remember yet these are the people that
Gershwin and people were going to see
who they were emulating like I said
ragtime was a hip-hop of its day and the
young boys that love that music we're
trying to figure it out they were trying
to learn from these these guys and so
I'm so I interviewed not long ago was
Katherine Hepburn and they were asked
you about Spencer Tracy should oh she
loved he loved Bert Williams and now and
we see spirits of tracing movies how
much he pan of Mines a lot of his film
was not dialogue there's a panel on
quality you can see the Bert Williams
commit could actually even to someone
like Spencer Tracy and that's kind of
lost us and that's part of my effort
just try to sort of show these these
connections but within the proximity of
the name
it's how they cross culturally related
to one another in this theatre life and
how popular life sometimes gets
transpose this other kind of Americana
that doesn't really reflect the
participation of all of us and I
lighting fly to drag thing and they show
all ties to african-americans tall ones
they go to wish I'd dance it's almost
like you can put it again Soul Train
when you see the movie it's like the
couple's come forward and dance to go
forward is tall and shortening I saw you
can run is like the Soul Train it's just
exactly the same everybody so full with
herself even forgot their partner it's
all about doing this line dance and so
they really play off this the character
types they get is showing a variety of
who we are not just a sort of simplistic
sense of who people think we might be
and this is a 19 this is 1914 so you see
there's these strides that are happening
because we know Bert Williams did
blackface and all this oh we can't touch
this I also feel like we should be
ashamed of nothing